let me
read the script and then we'll start
with the uh
attendance nationally
[Laughter]
good morning as chair of the labor
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of cobit 19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule
67 and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on all bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
executive session
may be held on any bill referred to the
committee this is an executive session
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order i
am confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
extemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rule rsa
9 rsa 91
a anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271 3600
or email hcs.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll
call vote let's start the meeting by
taking
the roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know law
mr clerk please call the role
representative
present at work employees around
we did not hear you representative brody
you're on mute um
i'm in my home office in manchester and
someone will be coming in and out
representative bouchard um
i'm home and alone in manchester
representing boy at home in my office
anyone with you no one is with me
representative cahill
uh home in new market alone in the room
representative calla present in the lob
representative esparestera
i'm here in nashua in my living room
representative mackey
representative nunez in my home office
alone
i'm present and alone in my home office
representative seaworth i'm here in the
llp
representative at home alone
representative sullivan at home in my
home office
my wife is around and about
representative
at home alone uh my wife is upstairs
representative jerichod president and
the lobby
representative love here in the lobby
representative infant game here in the
lob
with all my comrades around
okay um we are now going to uh
stand for the pledge of allegiance brian
would you please please
yes i pledge allegiance to the flag
of the united states of america
one nation under god
i recited before we are here in the llb
we have removed our jackets as it is
very warm in here no air conditioning
and we're doing our best
i went out folks and bought this really
cool state of new hampshire
seal mask and uh
i think it'd be better to look at than
something else and it took me a while
because i had to find one that was made
in the united states
so i found one and now we don't need the
mass anymore so i guess that's good for
for all of us but i at least had to show
off my cool mask
please remember when we are voting today
it's a courtesy to everyone if you would
like to show your face
obviously when you're speaking i would
like that when you're speaking
[Music]
to have your zoom camera on that is not
required but it's courtesy
however it is required that you have
your face
showing um on
and not just your picture when we are in
a voting mode and you do
cast your vote
being said i'm going to start the um
executive session
on senate bill 123
relative to employer payments require
covid 19 testing
and i recognize representative seaworth
for a motion
thank you mr chairman i uh moved this
bill on to pass and i have an amendment
uh
you're recognized to speaking of your
bill and your amendment all right my
amendment
is number one six three eight
h um i sent this around to the committee
hopefully
everyone got it and had a chance to
glance at it
i have to credit our chairman for doing
the
thinking for most of this i got my name
on it but
he did a lot of the work i know for
myself
the public hearing i think we were
generally in favor of this bill but
there were a few
concerns raised during the hearing there
were some others that came up afterwards
and so i wanted to take a closer look at
this bill
our chairman actually did as we often
like to do on this committee he
contacted the department of labor
and asked them uh how big is this
problem
is this uh is this a common issue and
their answer was
not really
they cited about a dozen issues
related to coven 19 not necessarily
necessarily this specific issue anything
from the vaccines to the testing to
are you on the clock when you go off to
get your test
so it's it's not clear to me that they
have
actually had issues exactly like what
we're addressing in this bill
what they did say though is if someone
does come to them and says hey
my employer required me to go get a test
and when i came back he said
they're not paying for it they would say
that's not right
the law requires that employers
pay for any medical examination that
they require
so with that information the chairman
called a meeting with the senator
sponsors of this bill and we had some
discussions
and uh actually he suggested wouldn't
this be simpler if we just replace all
that
added language with one word test
and uh one of the senators said i was
just going to say the same thing
so that's what i have drafted instead of
a new
section which adds some specific
language
uh to deal with covid19
and actually duplicates a paragraph
that's already in the law
we added with this amendment we would
add one more word
test to medical examination and
records as the things that if an
employer requires from an employee
they also have to pay for it as i said
from the department of labor standpoint
this is how they would apply the
existing law so it's not really a change
but what we did hear from the senators
is they believe
there is some confusion out there and
some disagreement on what the existing
law means
and this would clarify it it also is not
specific to
coven 19 anymore if there's a cove at 22
it would also apply if there's any other
medical issues
it makes clear as the department already
uh
and would enforce that medical testing
is part and parcel of a medical
examination
so i ask you please adopt this amendment
thank you brian i was a little out of
order um i may i please have a second
second by representative my apologies
for not having that
is now made the most is made and second
it is open for discussion representative
k
l i see your hand you're recognized to
speak uh
i was going to second but uh mr church
beat me to it
oh well thank you uh thank you
um are there any questions or excuse me
anyone else
would like to um speak on behalf of
the the bill as ought to pass with
amendment or against
anyone here in the lobby
i don't see any anyone online would like
to speak
for or against the motion on the floor
with amendments
mr chair don't we have to vote on the
amendment first
yes we do um it is um we don't
vote on it before we have discussions so
i i don't understand representative
sullivan
yes we do have to vote on the amendment
uh and then it could be open to any
other additional amendments
and then we would vote on each
individual amendment and then the final
um but there's the motion on the floor
is out to pass an amendment
and then now it's open for discussion
representative abulani
thank you mr chairman um i have a
question relating to the executive
orders
if the government requires a negative
test coming back from vacation for
a possible exposure and the employer has
to require that will the employer have
to
again pay for that test even though it's
not required through the employer policy
do it is the understanding of the
chairman and the vice chairman
in our communications with the
department of labor that they
do consider that to be the current law
now
that is how questions were brought are
brought to them by an
employer or an employee they would state
that that's what they feel
rsa 275 colon 3
states and all we are doing is trying to
codify that and make it more specific
the answer to your direct answer to your
question is
yes mr chairman thank you mr chairman
here uh representative on avelani's
question again please
representative would you please um
repeat your question one more time for
uh representative turcotte
yes um if uh an employee doesn't require
a covet test to return to work
if there is something that happened
outside of their location
you know they went to a family wedding
they went on vacation yet
the executive orders require a negative
test to return to work or negative
testing not quarantine or a negative
test to
anything like that is the employer going
to have to pay for that negative test
pay for that test in order in order for
them to return to work even though it is
outside the scope of the employer policy
and uh why i'm not the department of
labor that is my understanding
thank you mr chairman is that okay uh
representative
yes it was thank you very much
thank you mr chairman in answer to that
i i think
the representative has probably hit on a
gray area that
department of labor would have to
address
i think you are first of all i
absolutely correct that
this bill doesn't change
they would address that in a certain way
i'm not entirely sure what it was
this bill wouldn't change that uh the
way the law applies
but it is an interesting question what
if the employer doesn't require it but
some other entity does
at what point does it become um
as the language says a a condition of
employment
and i i don't know if we have enough
information to fully answer that
getting back to we have a motion motion
on the floor
of to pass an amendment um
i'm happy to take other questions uh
also um you're
allowed now this is the time period to
you to speak in favor or against the
bill representatives
didn't say what other entity would
require that
i think his example was so there's a
state requirement that if you've
traveled out of state you must take the
test
before you return to work and that's not
me as the employer
requiring that but if i but state law
says that i have to
so am i requiring it or not and
and that i i don't know how to answer
that
because the employer requires it that
the employer is paying
the same thing as a drug test like you
know if there was some
weird sort of chance for the state of
new hampshire wants you to pass a
drug test in order to come back then
this
you know that's not on the employer
that's at the state i just i don't
think it's terribly great no i agree i
would think if the state requires the
employer to do it the employer would
then have to
um just a moment i have a representative
espicia and then representative
well i was going to say we have thank
you mr chair we have rudy ogden if you
wanted to
department on so if you wanted uh
he is here what did i ask him oh he's
the only one
and he's got to stand up so he might be
willing to address
sorry rudy i didn't i have two screens
here i have to go back and forth here
and looks of my apologies
assistant commissioner ogden you're
recognized to speak
on that matter thank you representative
speech
and representative turkoff for pointing
that out
i don't see rudy um
space there he is and he's out
hi thank you uh chairman thank you
members of the committee
um happy to answer any questions in
terms of the specific
question that's come up relative and to
uh if there was an order the
department's uh position on that would
the
whether the order is generated
ultimately from the state
or put in place by the employer if the
employee
would need that in order to work or if
the employer
was in some way facilitating that by
saying okay in order to come back to
work
you're going to need that the department
would view that as employer
driven and it would be a condition of
employment at which point time again we
would say that
uh lab-80302 uh
would require that's an existing
regulation
would require the employer to bear the
costs associated with that
as representative seaworth said earlier
uh the department views again
through uh 275 3
and lab-80302 that
this type of testing already should be
covered and paid for
by the employer certainly this could be
looked at as a clarification of that
however
thank you are there any other questions
involved
okay getting back to the uh
motion is ought to pass with amendments
our would anyone like to speak in favor
or against the motion on the floor
anyone here in the lob wish to speak
anyone online on zoom wish
to speak
you guys are not nice to me this morning
representative you recognize to speak
yeah um as business owner
uh i i would like to hear if he would
like to i'm
requesting representative to speak
on this issue as to the point he brought
up this
at would that change
or alter his position
on the current amendment
if he chooses to speak to it if he
doesn't that's i but i would like to
hear his opinion
um as long as we don't get too out of
control
and debating each other i will allow a
simple question
representative if you're willing to
speak you may or you may
choose not to thank you mr chairman no
it has not changed my
ability to
vote in favor of this amendment i just
wanted clarification on just
the outside of the employer's realm if
this would still have to be paid by the
employer
thank you representative okay i see no
other
questions or comments
online or here in the llb
so the motion on the floor is ultra pass
with amendment 1638h
we're ready for the roll call vote
clerk you may call roll
down in seaworth yes
see where the votes yes
representative avalon yes
representative callum yes
representative mackey
representative love yes
representative chaircott representative
turpa folks yes
representative proud
votes yes
senator susie representative soucy votes
yes
representative arudy representative rudy
vocess
representative cahill cahill votes yes
representative especially
representative bouchard votes yes
administrators yes
engineer representative votes yes
absolutely i mean it's
yes the vote is affirmative
okay the uh ought to pass where the
amendment
um is adopted and
the bill is open to any additional
amendment
huff thank you
chairman infant tank we're actually not
able to hear representative huff
online you want to get closer to a
microphone that would be helpful
we will get the microphone closer to him
looks like he's muted
he has to be muted on his computer or
you're gonna have feedback
representative you could speak a little
louder yes recognize
can everybody hear me now yes sounds
great
thank you um
i would like to offer an amendment
to this what is the amendment number
representative
the amendment number i'm not sure what
it is at the moment
because it's going to be coming in
from christina the one that i had sent
out to everybody that can follow along
um is like john i represent
i'm gonna i need to interject just a
little bit here first of all
representative mackey has joined us
thank you very much remember
mackie sorry about the problems getting
you the correct number um
christina i would
yes we have an amendment and it is being
processed if it is not available
to be submitted right now to
each individual committee member by
email
could if it's not ready at this point we
have an eta
i would anticipate um i don't it is not
ready right this minute
but i anticipate it's going to be ready
quite soon
okay i am reluctant to um have you
introduce
or discuss an amendment that is wrong
and that is why we noticed the amendment
was wrong
about half an hour 45 minutes ago
and i'm reluctant to have you do that
to bring up something that is not even
going to be discussed or or
accurate i understand the topic is the
wording
so
and can we recess this bill
work on the other one no i don't want
that all right
um i'm going to i think it's just
inappropriate folks i mean
if you would like i will leave it up to
the committee um
if you would like to hear the concept of
the and then wait for it or just wait
for it to come
i don't want to cause additional
confusion representative can you
recognize him
mr chairman i i have a previous
commitment
uh a dear friend has passed away and i
do want to go to the memorial service
and the late start is a problem i i
really hope to vote on both of these
bills
i really can't wait for something else
to happen in the games room
thank you representative
[Music]
that being said in order to try to move
this along
i am going to let oh i have a question
here and then i will
finish representative um
i'd like to make a motion to retain
sb-123
as
there's a higher motion i believe
there is that emotion on the floor to
retain
senate bill is everybody's
second i'll say uh second
representative seaworth you may uh speak
to your motion
point of order yes
don't i understand that we should
dispose of the motion on the floor
before we take up another motion
we now have two motions on the floor
that is going to pull out my
parliamentary
encyclopedia on the back of my head but
more often than not on the floor of the
house we have
a motion on the floor when a higher
emotion takes precedent
um it someone can someone can
tell me i'm wrong and i'm not going to
be offended
uh when a higher emotion comes forth
my understanding is it squashes the
amendment or the emotion on the floor am
i incorrect
i believe the higher motion on the floor
of the house is the tabling motion
um we don't have a tabling motion in
committee
point of order mr chairman uh
thank you representative sullivan i need
to have clarification on this before
but yes representative turcotte i don't
believe we have a motion on the floor
ought to pass the amendment and then it
was open to further
open further amendment further amendment
that is the motion on the floor
okay
is going to call the clerk to make sure
we are doing everything correct
representative
mr chair we have a we have an amendment
that really improves the bill
a bill that we all seem to agree is a
good bill
and i would really hope that we could
just vote ought to pass on the amendment
and
move on to the next bill
i would like to do that representative i
have an appropriate amendment that it
was presented to me
uh a day ago
and i believe it was emailed to everyone
so everyone has seen it there was a
technical
because we can't um
there was a wording that questioned
that was incorrect by legislative
services
in that part said it replaced the entire
bill
well that's not what the goal was the
goal was to add an additional amendment
so um trying for the last
hour to get this done
and and uh i'd like to have that
either up or down if it can't be here in
the next 10 minutes then i'm gonna have
to
continue with the and i'm gonna i won't
be able to accept this motion
or an additional amendment and then the
other things are open but uh
so uh representation has a resp um
clarification for us so so just to
clarify mr clerk
the motion to retain is not in order
because the motion is not higher motion
and otpa has to be dealt with first is
that correct
yes
okay so if the otpa is withdrawn
from a speaker then another one can be
made
okay so we can't retain it after the
otpa motion but if we withdraw the otpa
motion
then we can make a motion for retainment
okay okay
all right thank you all right
so we can the clerk said
otpa has to be dealt with in one form or
another before
we can uh either repeal otpa
and then do retain we can defeat an otpa
motion and then
um but we can't thank you very much
my question uh to the point of order
is it's my understanding
it's my understanding what we just did
was we did
pass representative seaworth's amendment
otp
with amendment we already passed that
we hadn't gotten to my amendment
so i don't know that mine is even a
question
at the moment
may i withdraw my commitment
you may but i would rather get a five
minute
if it's not here um i have to move on
okay so i would ask that you
call christina go to the elevator see
what you can get done to get this thing
in everyone's hands for the next five
minutes before we have to
watch wilton
[Music]
which amends
we are at the point that any amendment
could be made or
the actual motion
could be brought
as
brought forward three things can be done
number one
is open to other amendments if we have
an amendment to review
and pass and we can discuss it and
either approve it or not
we can take the existing bill as amended
representative's amendment and we can
vote on that
we can withdraw the off-capacity
amendment
vote on that to withdraw it and then
retain the bill
i would like to do one of the first i'd
like to amend it
if we can't get the amendment in the
next five minutes or so ten minutes then
we're going to
request and pass it with
or withdraw and retain
i'm sorry for interrupting i i was
thinking we already recessed but
i apologize uh you talked i'm really
fine
okay so
and i i'm not 100 sure i've got this all
right because committees are different
than the house floor
but in order to get a bill in discussion
i made the motion ought to pass
and then offered an amendment to that
bill
so the motion on the floor as we
discussed with the clerk was
the otpa
that i made at the very beginning to
bring the bill into discussion
and that's why the clerk said that in
order to
do anything different i have to withdraw
that motion
before we have to vote on it because i
already made
that function
um
yes
it's written it sucks
let's pick the helmet part
oh
because
it's like i used to get letters when i
was in the service that was like oh
thanks for uh volunteering for this
three-week off like i did not volunteer
for next
week thanks
my brother was in the reserve after he
got out of the army and he got one of
those letters that was saying oh we're
going to be
looking for volunteers for that he was
out of the reserve
the next day
cheers
actually it could have been worse
because public hearings the clerk has
more to do executive sessions you just
it's just recording the votes which
isn't too bad when it's a long public
hearing
the clerk has some work
you don't want
i don't know if anybody could hear it on
the on the zoom call
the chairman briefly came in and out he
said that the amendment is
done and he's just trying to get it
to us and
then he went back out to work on that
thanks for the update
shhh
sitting in the section
yes
get next
something
[Music]
oh there it is
my concern is representative love
anesthesia
may not have it christina i know you're
listening
you can make
to get this going
you're looking at lines 16-21
oh yeah
uh representative infantine how many
copies do you need
i'm printing 10 right now that would be
sufficient everyone's paying them online
okay i can also put it on the screen if
that's helpful to anyone
that'd be helpful
oh
yeah putting this up here christina for
the public
please amendment i guess
758 each
[Music]
that was
chairman before we discuss it will it be
introduced
and seconded
just ask
did someone have their hand rigged
thank you mr chairman i i i do see the
bill
and the amendment and the concept hasn't
changed although
maybe an error was corrected i
i don't know what's involved with final
fda approval
but i but i believe that the employers
and
other entities would use what's
available while you know
an emergency and uh what's what's
available
uh maybe have provisional fda approval
uh much like the vaccine so i i would
have to vote against this amendment i
don't think it's necessary or conducive
first of all with this backup we gotta
uh
why is this my name um
how do i recognize myself or amen
well i think any member representative
can make the motion
even though it's yours thank you
representative you're recognized to
uh the vote let's open for further
amendment recognition
thank you mr chair thank you for
committing uh for your indulgence
um i would like to propose amendment
one seven five eight h
is that a second sec
recognized to speak to your motion thank
you
um one of the things that i uh
was very very concerned about
in this atmosphere of covet
is it being
used to force folks
to take an unproven
possibly dangerous injection
as a condition of work so what i wanted
to have
happen here is just make it
so that and it's coveted 19 specific
um so to have that
not be a condition of employment
until it has got final
fda approval and the reason being is is
things like this take
five ten as many years because you need
to see the side effects you need to see
what's going on for all of these things
to come out
um once that has come out
this would be moved so this is just it's
a protection
for people who do not want to take
an unproven drug
and then i just added uh in the second
paragraph that paragraph one
should not apply to health care
providers
because i know that that in many many
cases
they have to do those things uh
regardless
so that's my amendment and if anybody
has any questions i'd be more than
willing to
entertain point of order mr chairman i
don't think the amendment
is
because this mr german was a bill to
deal with the payment
for tests um and now we're introducing
language
uh similar to some of the language
that's being introduced
or being considered as an amendment for
hb 155
for um relative to vaccines they're the
cova tests and vaccines are do
completely different things if this
wanted to be put somewhere else
and maybe it's got some legitimacy but i
firmly believe that it's not your name
[Music]
there payment for cobit 19 testing
now it's a completely different area i
haven't eaten this great but
i just want to
mr chairman yes it's my understanding
that the
chairman of the committee has ruled this
amendment germain
well i was thinking in the u.s to be
recognized
so uh
i'm going to make sure that i have my
thought process as to why i believe it's
true
thank you
well i while this does say required
focus testing
actually required testing payment of
testing
i do believe because it's dealing with
this
issue in there if this were just
if the original bill was for
any type of just generic testing i would
say
i would say
right there
all right could you please proceed to
take down the uh
chair so i can see everybody here
okay the motion of the floor has
any
i have to agree with representative
cahill actually i'd also agree with
representative edgerton about the
whether or not this is germaine but
furthermore i think
i can support this bill as originally
amended earlier in this uh hearing
um i cannot support it with uh this
further amendment on it
um for public safety purposes
thank you
thank you um i definitely think that
this uh
amendment uh definitely adds value and
does make uh
things better i definitely think that we
should not be allowing employers outside
the specialized circumstance of
healthcare providers
to require a vaccination that has not
gone through the
full battery of tests and been evaluated
for all the edge cases
and uh contrary indicators that will be
found in the
the final approval process and so i
support this amendment
thank you representative speaker
followed by representative
um thank you mr chair i mean i i i
cannot support this amendment when we
when folks are denied you know
employment by their employers for far
less um than than this
i mean i understand employers have to
make this decision and that is
that is up to them and so i i just i
can't
support some women in good faith
why do healthcare workers have to be
required to take the vaccine as a
condition of employment
if it's so darn dangerous when you know
we're i that that last line made me
think of
why we're creating a situation of
extended living circumstances
where some folks based on the condition
of employment would be required to get
the vaccine
but not everybody else has to why is the
healthcare field special there
amendment the difference in his opinion
between
final approval and final authorization
from the fda
yes um all drugs
have to go through a process this
particular one was fast-tracked
without any of the clinical backup and
studies to make sure that there are no
horrible side effects
i just wanted to take its natural course
that's all
it's more just a comment i'm i i'm
frustrated by this amendment because
part of the reason why we have
hesitation with encouraging folks
you know i'm not i'm not a mandatory
vaccination person either but part of
the frustration is that
you know we have had
three by my count including this pieces
of legislation aimed at raising
questions over the safety
uh and the consistency of a vaccine that
has not had any major um
health issues in anybody that it's been
applied to
yeah it was the you know seven people
that got blood clots with the johnson
johnson vaccine
birth control gives people more blood
clots than that vaccine did
so i'm not gonna vote for the amendment
i'm
i'm angry because we are trying so hard
to get out of this pandemic and by
raising questions like this in these
hushed tones where we
just want to be concerned um it's it's
raising doubts in people's minds that
unfortunately don't need to be fair so
that's just my commentary on that
thank you any other comments here in the
llp
thank you mr chair uh i'm not sure
whether or not
my colleague from laconia has read the
package insert on any medications
or seed commercials you know there's
always a disclaimer
all medicines have side effects and
you know if you're allergic to this
ingredient or that ingredient you know
talk to your physician
the vaccines are very very safe uh
speaking from personal experience i've
had two doses with no issues at all
and i i can't support this amendment i'm
sorry we
spent so much of our time on it
just for the record uh the safety of
these vaccines
uh is definitely a question uh my my
roommate uh took a trip to the booming
last week
was from the phone and ran into an old
friend of his uh
the guy's 30 year old daughter okay a
school teacher
uh athletics coach she's an athlete
herself uh he's dead from the backseat
meteors and talents it's happening all
over the country
i mean my fear of the vaccine is just as
much as anybody else's
thank you the chairman's going to um
give his opinion
um i have taken the vaccine
as you know i was always wearing these
things in this room even though i've
been
safe not to i have taken unbelievable
protocols and precautions i've been
around seven people
over the last year that were positive
including being with the speaker of the
house four days
before he passed um and i did not
contract at the best of my knowledge and
i'm happy to do that because i used
sometimes you saw me people laugh at me
that sometimes i wore two masks
at some of these events um i have taken
the vaccine
i have two um daughters
19 and 21 years of age one of them as a
friend of the military
i told all the ladies in the military if
you're planning on having children the
next five years
don't take the vaccine this came from
the united states military within their
ranks
people on the online doctors say oh it's
great don't worry
it's not going to deal with menstrual uh
cycles or or anything
or births other people say no don't take
it
we have a year to wait we're getting
tremendous amount of data
millions and millions of people 100
million people have taken this
vaccine at least completely
but my daughters have to take a vaccine
if they want to go back to college
they're questioning whether they want to
do that
it's their bodies it's their thing we
always talk about this it's a woman's
body don't tell a woman what to do
uh don't make and don't inhibit people
from getting jobs minorities some
minorities are the ones not getting it
they don't either have access to it or
they don't think they have access to it
so this it just surprises me
that the roles seem to be turned here
where the republicans want to make it
so if someone chooses not to have a
vaccine it's not impeding their ability
to get a job
uh which we're always accused of putting
things in place to people not be able to
get jobs
um 20 of the people won't get it
there's been 10 000 people in this
country that have gotten
coveted after receiving the vaccine
i don't think any of them have died or
maybe very few
so they're working and i would like
people
to get vaccines i'm not going to tell my
daughters what to do
and i as an employer
we have 80 employees all across the
country
the 10 or 15 here in new hampshire i
have a few of them that are not going to
take it
they will not take the vaccine i'm not
going to make their job predicated on
them
taking the vaccine i don't think that's
right as an employer
um so that is why i will be supporting
this i didn't expect it to come up i
didn't know
until a couple a day or so ago but um
the more i think about it i'm
this helps the people that don't want to
take it um
still retain a job i don't want people
coming to me
coming to this committee next year or
for you know i'm saying
you know our unemployment rate's higher
because these people won't take the
vaccine for their health reasons
yet or religious exemptions or whatever
so they can't get a job
uh those are my comments i one last one
from representatives
uh love one last comment and that
representative
you know uh legislature we have a member
that's a retired
project manager on
he's not
representative nunez
thank you mr chairman um i will support
this amendment i think
i think when we talk about these things
we're talking about individual liberty
and individual liberty belongs to the
person not to an organization
not to a company not to the government
it belongs to the person
and that person has a has the right to
make a decision
on whether or not they would like any
type of medical intervention on their
body
so i will be supporting this amendment i
know that
i know that i have had stories that have
been told to me by people that i know
who have taken this vaccine that had
some adverse re um
effects from it and i will say that a
male representative who i will not say
his name for privacy purposes was
at my home last weekend after receiving
the johnson johnson shot
and i had to make up a bed for him to
lay down in for several hours because it
basically just knocked him out
so um that i'll tell you that story i'm
not telling you who the person is
um uh i will be supporting this
amendment because i believe that it has
to do with individual liberty
thank you any additional comments online
i see any hands
any in the lobby
thank you mr chairman just for
clarification the vaccine
having side effects afterwards it's not
an indication
that it's secretly killing you um
i'm i've registered my frustration with
this earlier i think it's just
incredible
that we've managed to nestle ourselves
in the incredibly incredibly thin
crevice of the center of the venn
diagram between
people who in about 20 minutes or so are
going to say that we can't mandate
employers
pay anymore because that's the decision
of that business owner
but also that business owner does not
have the freedom or
does not have the purview over their
business to
say no i don't want you know a risk of
coping coming back because this pandemic
has been so terrible
has killed so many people has done so
much untold
damage to this economy that we do not
want to deal with this again
so i'm absolutely now on this amendment
thank you so you know other additional
comments there's emotion on the floor
ought to pass with the amendment
representative seaworth seaworth votes
yes
mackey votes yes
representative nunez votes yes
representative representative turcotte
yes
representative law representative love
votes yes
representative proud proud votes yes
representative boyd boyd vote
votes yes representative sullivan
so open votes no
[Music]
do me votes no
representative bouchard representing
representative bouchard votes now
representative adjutant action let's
know
yes
nine yes i'm sorry
nine nose and 11 yes
amendment passes the bill is open for
further amendment are there any
additional amendments
sitting down the motion on the floor is
ought to pass
as a as amended by
past cemented by amendment 1638
seaworth and 1578 by infant time
and point of order mr chairman the way
oh okay 1758 was drafted
it completely replaces uh 1638 so only
1758. the motion of the floor is ought
to pass
as amended
number 2021-1758
thank you chairman um sitting over here
i have the ability to look at
the sponsors list for sb 123.
uh it's pretty evenly split there are
five democrats and three republicans
um in a time of excise
political polarization conspiracy
politics
um i just i think it's so unfortunate
that this legislation is now wildly
different
than as was originally proposed in this
bipartisan way
to do something good for folks who
otherwise would have their employers
shift costs onto them
it's gonna be a fun media conference
because you know
it's it's incredibly different so i
guess we'll see how that pans out
any other comments on uh in the lobby
any comments online
representative espisia you're recognized
thank you mr chair
and i would just like to echo the
comments of my colleague
from um from from um
from bridgewater but just uh you know
it's
it's really sad um i i
like we just poison pilled a good bill
which you know isn't the first time
we've done this
in the house it's not the first time
we've done it had happened in the senate
um you know in in the legislature we've
you know had a real a pretty good bill
that had bipartisan support and and just
see it you know
you know now just torn the flames
because of because
of some because of what
folks thought so i'm just i'm really sad
i will be voting against this bill
uh would have voted for it originally
but you know now
i met the amendment has changed this
bill completely so i will be voting
against it
thank you any other hands
online
seeing none i will uh respond
representative out of it you're right
it's vastly different um
the way it is uh you can go out and
glide we're gonna have a
probably uh media conference
and confident however that with the way
the department of labor is
adjudicating the uh request any way that
they will be requiring in the meantime
in the least requirement as they do now
the employer pay for this test
um see no other hands uh comments
clark please call
[Music]
representative nunez votes yes
senator lopez yes
representative representatives yes
representative
votes yes
representative sullivan eleven votes now
representative two c votes no
schmidt votes no
representative me representative
to me votes no
[Music]
representative bouchard votes no
representative action
yes
motion passes um i i need the
uh whoever's going to write the um uh
blurb in favor and against i i need
those by uh close of business today if
not sooner
yeah the next bill on
in front of us is senate bill 137
representative seaworth you're
recognized
thank you mr chairman i uh make a motion
to pass and i have an amendment
second emotions please move your
amendment first
uh and i would like to move amendment
six 15968 seconded by president turcotte
you
you're uh recognized to speak on your
amendment
thank you mr chairman um i
thought my last amendment was going to
be the easy part
i hope that is enough or telling of
what's going to happen here
um this amendment once again um
when we listened to this bill in the
public hearing
there were a number of concerns some of
them i raised some of them i heard
around the table
some of them i heard from across the
table
i think i think both sides
were concerned about the way this bill
was worded
and um so with this amendment i tried to
simplify the language not really change
anything with the intent of the bill so
much but
try to clean up the language and some of
the confusing things were in there
um the first thing i did was uh
the the original bill did three things
more or less uh it it addressed this
45 percent number
that's that's in the bill for this base
rate
for tip wages it had its cigar bars
as an employer who could use the tip
rate and it also
added employees who were licensed
as charity casino dealers essentially
to be able to use the tip rate and it
was that last
piece that uh i found
convoluted the language and
after discussing with the bill's
sponsors and the supporters
um including uh the gentleman who was
representing the casinos
uh i felt it cleaned up the bill quite a
bit to remove that
um i i won't go into the details but i'm
happy to answer more questions about
that
so those employees are removed from this
bill
which greatly cleans up
the remaining elements i think it
simplifies it i
it makes it straightforward i also
kind of flipped around the way the
wording was done
um the original bill emphasized that the
327 which is what 45 725
is and is the current law um
it emphasized that and as the department
of labor brought up that created a
problem
if the federal rate actually went up
higher than that
then it created this conflict where the
state law was one thing but the federal
law which really applies is different
so the language flips that around to
make it clear that the federal law
is what applies except that we won't go
below the current rate
um so i think those
changes are straightforward i i think it
simplifies the bill
and we can discuss the the bill itself
after we vote on the amendment
they
want to speak in favor or against the
bill as amended here in the lobby
anyone would like to speak on the bill
as amended
online
see none
clerk can we call the role
mr chairman to clarify we are voting for
the commitment
representative sullivan um we are voting
on the amendment not otpa correct
we're voting on the amendment thank you
amendment number one
five nine six eight
representatives seaworth votes yes
yes
ots
representative is she votes now
hill votes yes
schmidt votes no
representative toomey votes yes
representative bouchard representative
bouchard votes no
representative votes now
infantine votes yes
yes the amendment passes and the bill is
open for further amendment
representative attitude
thank you mr chairman um i'd like to
introduce amendments
uh 1366h to sb-137
um representative
has moved amendment 13 66
uh the second of the motion oh second
second by representative bouchard
recognized
speaking thank you mr chairman um my
emotion
my amendment is pretty simple um the
original
sponsor of the bill thought that 725 was
good enough for some folks i think it's
good enough for everybody
um 327 is
um a ridiculous joke and
i'll speak further to that after
hopefully this amendment has passed
um but we're talking about what's good
for some what's good for all
uh let's put everybody on the level
playing field in their opinion and pass
this amendment
very well um
the uh is the floor is open for speaking
in favor or against the amendment are
there any comments or
uh here in the lob representative
seaworth
uh thank you mr chairman um
i was happy to see that we got some
bipartisan support for my amendment
but i have no illusions that that means
that there's
support for the bill i know we have some
there's a lot of conflict over the
subject of minimum wage
and particularly the subject of tip
minimum wage there's a lot of opinions
i'm going to go out on a limb and i'm
going to say that i think
where this agreement is
and evidenced by uh the amendment from
my fellow representative
is that the 45 number it
doesn't really make sense um i
i think chair mr chairman you said we're
the only state in the nation that
actually
tries to do this as a percentage why 45
that's really hard to justify i wasn't
here
uh when the 45 number was originally put
into law
i was here um when we
changed the minimum wage to tie it
directly to the federal rate
rather than kind of mirroring it with
our own language
and i know we kept the 45 percent at
that time
um and i can speculate as to why that
might have happened at that time
this was i think ten years ago if you
had said
okay the federal rate is going to go up
um what might it go up to eight dollars
might have been a good guess
as to what to expect next at the federal
level
and when you apply the 45 to 8
that's a 30 increase in the tip rate
and you know is that the right number
does it really matter when you're
talking about 30 cents
20 cents nowadays
eight dollars i would say is next to
impossible to see that
as as the proposal for what the minimum
wage should be
um and and certainly during the
the hearing we talked about what's
currently on
um being proposed at the federal level
but really it could be anything and i
think we need to anticipate that it
could be 9
10 12 15. we had a bill that was 23.50
which the 45 would drive it up
then to 11 something would be our our
tip minimum wage
uh which is a lot more than any of our
neighboring states and it could be
devastating
for the hospitality
industry so
the argument then is what is the right
number
and i i
don't like the characterization that
we're telling everybody to
to pay 327 that is what it is now
and the way this is written is it sets
a floor to that but if the feds
change their rate
and it's still below 327 that we don't
go
down to their rate that we only go up to
their new rate
i think that's a conservative way to
deal with
the simple fact that we don't know
what's going to happen
with federal law and
trying to pass something that
anticipates that that anticipates
what the other states in new england
might do as a reaction
um i think it's difficult and so that's
why i propose and i will continue to
support
this conservative approach that does the
same thing with the tip rate
follows the federal rate that we do with
the the minimum
rate overall um
i don't know that
725 is is
the perfect
and that's one number it
we could debate where it should be um
the other thing though that i want to
bring up
is we're not setting that as a rate for
people to be paid right now
um tipped employees some do get 7.25
some get something between 7 25 and 327.
some probably do get 327 but we're not
driving everybody to one rate we're
setting an absolute
floor in line with what what federal law
does
um just i
happen to present my version of the
amendment
to the representative for the cigar bars
and he said that they for one have no
intention
of lowering the rate that they pay their
bartenders
just because we authorize it
and i i think that's the way we have to
look at this this is a
anything with minimum wage is a floor
it's not a wage that we're requiring
employers to pay
stop with that because it
the is in which i saw them raised were
attitude and then
uh turcotte followed by love and then
we'll go online
thank you mr chairman i believe the
bipartisan agreement
in the vote a few minutes ago was more
intended to
clean up the language um that we all
agreed during the public hearing was a
little duplicatous
um the the reason why i put
um 725 in there
in instead of 45 in a perfect world
i would prefer the 45 or 45 number to be
there
um because i think that
um you know makes it easier as a
percentage
for the tipped minimum wage to keep
track with
whatever the federal is um but 725
was in the bill in a different point
regarding the charitable gaming folks so
um versus proposing an amendment
that was just literally the text in the
rsa
um i provided a germain amendment um
and tried to loop everybody up to the
language that
was already in the proposed legislation
so i that that's the situation on that
so i appreciate
my colleagues um recognition of a little
bipartisanship but i think a lot of that
was more
um inclined at cleaning up the two
paragraphs that were the exact same as
each other
you're right thank you chairman
um just uh question for the maker
uh in lines 10 through 13
much like the original bill that came
out of the senate uh
it appears we have paragraph in 10
through 13 that
for all intents and purposes is exactly
the same as 13 through 16.
when i asked senator bradley about that
his comment was
you know you guys can fix that so seeing
this and your amendment
is there a difference is there the
intent to be a difference
or is it a oversight
uh nope i think that unfortunately
was a different drafting error i don't
know why that wasn't
there when i went through it i purposely
deleted that part out
yeah it's the same drafting as the
initial one thank you
and continue on i i'll be against this
uh
amendment i think one of the things we
lose
track of or lose sight of here we've got
a state minimum tipped wage a federal
minimum tipped wage nobody
ever ever makes below the minimum wage
set at the federal level
because if the tip wage if they if they
don't get
make the minimum of 725 an hour the
difference is always made up
that is very very rare to begin with so
nobody's ever gonna in a tipped
wage is ever gonna make less than 725 an
hour
and it's been in testimony after
testimony here
we know that most tipped employees get
somewhere
north of 20 some as high as 30 and some
even
more when uh you look at some of the
higher end restaurants so i'll be
uh voting against this participant thank
you
thank you i need to take a few online
just a moment
with me with my representative do i have
any questions
questions comments online
lino representative abalani
you're recognized
uh thank you mr chairman um just for
clarification how would
a minimum wage paid employee as of today
if this was to pass and become law
how would they be required
to pay for beyonce
representative you broke up
significantly could you please ask
your question again
my apologies mr chairman um if we move
if this
amendment passes and the bill becomes
law as of this year
how how would the irs rules and
regulations for shipped employees
work if the chip employee now makes
minimum wage how would they be required
to claim any tips above and beyond
minimum wage
i i can only venture a guess i'm not an
irs agent nor do i
understand all the rules and laws but
there are people currently paying get
there are currently individuals that are
making more than 327 an hour
for tipped employees as tipped employees
just for their base rate from their
employer and then their tips on top of
that so i'm sure it's
still still legal regardless but
i can't answer your question qualified
tax preparer or
irs representative
have any other um you have any other
your comments on on the amendment
hearing none representative love and
then i'm looking for additional hands
online representative love you
recognized thank you chair uh
i'll be voting against this amendment um
i believe in letting the market dictate
the cost of labor or across the products
um you know it kind of reminds me in
order
to start off with you know for those of
us that are old enough to remember
the recessions in the 70s just sort of
devastating
businesses and not only knows if we're
going back lately
you know uh back in the 70s i was i was
driving
and it was a union job we were out on
strike and we went over to my
grandfather's house
you know i'm a young kid jumping up and
down we're going to get this we're going
to get that
the boss can't make the money nobody's
making money we're gonna make sure the
bosses can still make money
there's a there's a delicate balance
that we can't uh we can't
ignore you know if we can get 25 for a
hamburger
because the dishwasher is making 7.25 or
more
i don't see any additional questions
online
i'm going to well recognize your past
thank you mr chairman just real quick um
i emailed or i texted this to
um the members online that i had phone
numbers for and i printed off a copy
for all of my friends on the labor
committee today uh
following um representative glove's
commentary i just wanna
before we discuss it further in the
final bill turn everybody's attention to
the newsweek article that i attached to
your copy of the amendment
that's titled denny's shareholders
revolt
after top executive concedes 15
minimum wage won't hurt businesses the
article is about how
investors in the company denny's are
trying to leave the national
restaurant association because the
national restaurant association is
talking out of both sides of their mouth
telling the investors that actually a 15
an hour minimum wage and one wage for
everybody is
not gonna you know have cats and dogs
living together and fire breathing down
from the sky
and then lobbying politicians that
actually in fact it's going to be the
end of days
so uh before we discuss that further i
just wanted to take that opportunity to
bring that up
so that we're all having the same
discussion in a couple of minutes
thank you representative paul thank you
mr chairman
um i just wanted to say um
from the testimony that we got on this
bill
our senator and the bill sponsor
said in his testimony the raise of in
the required minimum wage
employees could manifest in a doubling
of that wage
this is almost what my colleague from
grafton county
is alluding to in his amendment um
the senator also went on to say it would
create duress and pressure on business
establishments
that would have the potential to put
businesses out of business it would
reduce employee hours and create
job loss this is the author of the bill
warning against
a higher rate and for that reason i am
going to
propose this amendment
so you know additional hands online
i applaud you for submitting your
amendment uh
i find it interesting and i had this
conversation with representative
sullivan on the phone yesterday or the
day before
this concept of getting rid of the 45
has been
passed around this legislature for a
number of years
most recently presented by senator donna
soucy my senator
um and actually i was surprised that
republicans wanted to vote for this
the democrats really didn't want to vote
for it because
this makes it easier quite frankly
to increase the minimum wage
because every time we have a minimum
wage issue
the biggest barkers are the tipped
employee
owners because of the 45
and it precludes the minimum wage from
going up
because that's always the that that the
tip part is always a problem
that's always the 45 oh we can't do that
they're already making more about well
that's always the problem
when you separate these into two
different things
it makes it easier to maybe you can
include increase one or maybe the other
or both whereas before it had to be both
so it actually makes it easier faster
than a wage
senator susie's bill had the minimum
wage increase to 12
with the tip weighs to four dollars
in her bill that passed the democrat-led
house and democrat
senate last year um
and it included getting rid of this 45
they were going to be their own separate
things
so now the same thing has been proposed
except brazil which i think we all can
agree
are raised by marketing and we're
already pretty much
there 4 and 12. so
it's interesting to keep the eye on the
ball of the concept here
we're adding we're having discussions
about
327 725
for the tip 725 whatever the concept
here that needs is the 45
getting rid of that allows this
legislature
a lot easier time to increase the
minimum wage should they see fit
so i apply what you've done
but i'll talk more about it in the final
bill but i hope my colleagues
keep the eye on this minimum wage
is being is a lot higher than the 725
even the tip ways people are paying more
i'll give examples of that when we have
our final discussion
real life stories here in the state of
new hampshire but it's the 45 percent
so when you when you vote on this
finally if you really want to increase
the minimum wage in the state of new
hampshire
that 725 you have a better choice of
dealing
with that 45 removed
i see all the questions uh hands raised
anywhere
would you please call the roll on
the
seaworth votes no
representative amalani
you're on youtube
fire mr chairman avilani votes now
senator callum votes no
representative mackey mackey vote snow
representative representative nunes
votes no
no
votes now
representative pop puff votes no
representative sullivan sullivan yes
yes
[Music]
representative toomey votes yes
representative bouchard votes yes
yes
[Music]
point of order mr chairman yes
uh excuse me for interrupting uh i did
not hear the count
on the on the amendment count from you
guys could you please repeat that
eight yes eleven no
i think that's the other way around
no that's correct
is that right the amendment was
presented by representative
yeah okay i was backwards thank you very
much thank you
so the motion on the floor is uh senate
bill 137
[Music]
1596 each
is hoping for comments
thank you mr chairman um i'd like to
speak to my motion briefly here and
first of all i apologize to any
colleagues that i
was putting words in their mouth or
thoughts in their head i certainly
wasn't trying to do that i was
going to be a little funny and maybe
failed um
but what's important to me here is that
again as i said before i know we have a
very contentious debate going on
in this house going on in this country
about
um what the minimum wage should be
and uh that
seeps into the argument over this bill
but it is my belief that's
not what this bill is about um
to me the bill is about the 45 percent
um
whether that's appropriate and i don't
think it is and i think it's important
that we remove the 45 percent number
um before it comes and and does
something
terrible to our businesses and it really
you know i i think we all got an email
from a restaurant owner
that talked about what the catastrophic
effects
could be if a huge
increase to this tipped rate
comes through and
the problem is we don't know what could
happen we've got this percentage that
automatically calculates
the tip rate without any deliberation
on the part of this legislature and i
think that's the problem
that needs to be fixed as i said before
and i won't dwell on it um
i think focusing on the 327
is not the way to read this bill what
this bill
does is sets our state minimum rate to
match the federal minimum rate
just as it is with the
minimum wage itself again i understand
that this is a contentious issue
we could debate whether that's the right
thing to do or the wrong thing to do
in my opinion that's not the focus of
the bill the focus of the bill is the 45
number i don't know if the chairman was
trying to
get me to waver in my support uh he may
have a point that taking the 45 percent
away
removes one of the big roadblocks to
getting a minimum
a state minimum wage wrong pass um
that that could be a that's a good point
because the 45
has this unintended consequence of
maybe a reasonable change to the minimum
wage
could be a very
critical change to this subset of
businesses that's relying
on this formula that the feds have
for crediting tips against the minimum
wage and calculating what needs to be in
the paycheck
but he did not convince me i am still
advocating for my bill to pass his
amendment
uh i don't know if i can get any
uh votes to swing my way but i'll ask
and i i hope we don't get into too much
of a debate about
setting the minimum wage because once
again i i don't think that's the purpose
of this bill
finally one thing i pointed out in the
email and i'll emphasize
it again just in case it's missed
is this not on the amendment page but in
the original bill there's a clause that
says this
does not take effect until the
federal government changes the minimum
wage
and that's i think we need to keep that
in mind that
passing this does absolutely nothing in
the near term
things remain exactly as they are until
it is triggered by action at the federal
government
and i think we need to see what that
action is
before we decide
our current law good enough or
or do we need to make further changes
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative thank you mr
chairman um
i would like to agree with my colleague
about the purpose of that the main focus
of this bill is the elimination of the
however that's not the way the sponsor
presented it to us the way the sponsor
presented it to us was
this is an effort to freeze the tips
minimum wage at 327
so um i would like to see it
through that lens however i'm gonna go
with the way that uh
senator bradley talked about it and
brought it to us um
today i'm asking the labor committee to
vote against the otpa motion
because put simply the bill is
quasi-constitutional and it is
good for anybody involved on the issue
of constitutionality the bill will be
by my count the fourth piece of
legislation advanced in this body that
seems to preemptively nullify federal
law
supremacy clause constitution clearly
states that so long as a federal law
does not violate the constitution
it takes effect over a conflicting state
law sponsor of the bill even agreed to
as much when he testified before the
committee
when he said quote if the feds raise the
tipped minimum wage
this conversation is over if the minimum
wage
were to increase the tipped one would
absolutely
uh take precedent and we know this
because as was explained to us in
hearing the raise the wage act
does include an increase to the tips
minimum wage
already zeroing out this language
leaving redundant language in the rsas
that strikes at the tenants of
federalism in my opinion is
counterproductive
why would we pass a bill that the
sponsor acknowledges has a slim
chance of relevancy on the issue of why
the bill isn't good for anybody involved
i want to bring some data into this
conversation according to the national
restaurant association statistics
from 2017 and 2018 states where there is
no sub
minimum wage are experiencing better or
the same restaurant growth
as states without them in fact as i
alluded to
the restaurant chain denny's is trying
to leave the
national restaurant association after
their shareholders had to admit
to their investors that the minimum wage
increase has been good for business
and a quote from the article in newsweek
dated may 5th
quote on an earnings call in february
denny's chief financial officer robert
varistak
told investors that the california law
raising the minimum wage to 15
an hour by 2023 has actually been
good for the diner chain as they've
increased their minimum wage kind of in
a tempered pace over the time frame
if you look at that time frame from us
california has outperformed the system
over that time frame they had six
consecutive years of positive
guest traffic not just positive sales
but positive guest traffic as the
minimum wage was going up
more people were participating at the
restaurant then prior
when the sponsor came to the committee
he said well if you raise the minimum
wage it'll lead to more automation
and i have heard the lore of the
mcdonald's robots for as long as i've
been alive
and now mcdonald's is offering
applicants iphones in some places to
work for them
because they so desperately need people
the sponsor said well if you raise the
minimum wage those places won't be able
to hire employees
now they can't hire employees because
some folks look at the possibility of
people getting paid in such a way that
they aren't the first generation of
americans in history
worse off than their parents and they
say how can we possibly pay these people
less
the restaurant owners association raised
concerns
that this is unnecessary because the
average worker makes
over 20 an hour with tips to which i say
please explain to me how one can
simultaneously believe that we have to
end the unemployment benefits early for
15 000 people
because that measly 300 a week benefit
quote
pays more than working does but working
also somehow pays 800
a week doesn't make a lot of sense to me
the fact of the matter is that these
people do
hard work i know a lot of people think
that being a server or a cook is easy
but it is not running around on your
feet dealing with impolite
and sometimes downward cruel customers
who take pride in the fact that they
don't tip
and all the other stuff they're forced
to put up with to maybe get a 5
tip is ludicrous you just raise the menu
prices a little bit
which will not impact your customer base
as was alluded to in the article
because eating out is still a fun thing
that people will do even if the chicken
salad goes from 9.99 to 10.99
and give your staff the security
of a paycheck that they can reasonably
plan on
at the end of every week so that they
may budget
and i promise you they will be happier
to work
for you folks know that i love to weave
historical themes into my remarks so i'd
like to close out this
uh with this incredibly relevant quote
by president franklin roosevelt
do not let any calamity howling
executive with an
income of a thousand dollars a day who
has been turning his employees over to
the government relief roles in order to
preserve his company's undistributed
reserves
tell you that a wage of 11 a week is
going to have a disastrous effect on all
american industry
thank you mr chair thank you and i do
enjoy
oh okay representative seaworth and i'm
going to ask people online all right
thank you mr chairman and i i do have a
question
um about your your comment you mentioned
the potential constitutionality issue
uh which i'd like you to clarify i
understand your point
relative to the original bill that came
over
um i understand it relative to some of
the comments from the sponsor
but certainly my intention in making
that
amendment was to remove that
constitutionality issue
if if it is indeed that and fix it um
well guys i i have an answer and
actually uh representative
i would refer you also back to something
that you closed out your remarks with
when you said
um we want to why why should we make any
sort of decision before we see
what the federal minimum wage ends up
being
like this between this um
the hr1 um bill that went before
election law the other day uh there was
another one that went before criminal
justice
um there's another one that i'm getting
off the top of my head it just it just
seems like there are so many
preemption bills um that
really play with the concept of
federalism and nullification
uh and again not by your interpretation
of removing the 45
i understand what you're saying on that
and i would agree with representative
infantine that that makes
it a little easier i'm referring to the
way the bill was characterized when it
came to us
which is if the minimum wage goes up
we are going to have our own special
little thing that
flies in the face of the supremacy
clause and crossed our fingers that it
works because it will destroy the
restaurant industry otherwise
that's that's that sort of nullification
concept that i'm feeling in some of
these bills
i don't want to debate but if you want
to ask
this is no longer uh a senator's bill
what he thought it did or what he wrote
if that language isn't here that's not
his bill anymore and
just to refer to my language as amended
it says that the base rate which is what
we call our typically
will not be less than the minimum direct
wage as
set forth in federal minimum wage law uh
minimum direct wage is what they call
their version of that same number so i
i wanted to very clearly say
federal law preempts us and we're going
to adopt that as state policy
if i'm contradicting someone else on
some other language
respectfully i ask that we consider the
language that's before us
and not what someone else thinks should
be done
if i can respond
yes um and i agree i understand
if we are making the language in so that
uh it catches up to the federal minimum
wage anyways then why even have the bill
because it's the same thing if the
tips i i also want to clarify that like
i wish i had the confidence that some
members do that the minimum wage is
going to go up
um i've been incredibly disappointed
with
some of the ways that certain senators
um
in dc have handled that bill um
i it just just feels like so much um
to insert in the rsa for something that
basically spells out
um that the minimum wage would just be
whatever the federal minimum wage is
anyways it just
feels like the language might not need
to be there so i appreciate the
amendment i understand the language
still disagree any comments i'm looking
for hands
yellow ones or real ones
online
i don't think i don't see it but
representative to me
no no
oh that might be the curse
we have like a the white hand is the
cursor
by your your face accent any comments
here in the lobby
speaker the chairman has a couple of
comments but any comments here
all right um you know i've worked
as a laborer in the hot sun
all through high school and college
building stone walls playing sod
i was a burger king assistant manager
um while i had a job as a trainee as an
insurance as an insurance company
so i've done some of these jobs and
um never never never really been a
tipped employee
but i know what it's like to to work and
want to see that minimum wage increase i
personally get this get this on camera
all your people
and give you a second but you want to
take this i personally believe the
minimum wage should be increased
for both tipped and non-tipped because
i'm sick and tired of hearing the
argument
we're paying people in excess of that
now one of my i'm going to use my
daughters again
one of my daughters came home that's
been working at old navy
ten dollars an hour folding clothes and
doing whatever she had uh
job seeking had three or four offers in
in the same day
she now makes uh in excess of 12 an hour
as a hostess at a restaurant
and she can garner tips for the takeout
my other daughter has worked at a
restaurant for the last five or six
years through her high school and now in
her college career
she makes 7.75
plus tips there are other companies out
there that have said i don't care about
the 327
an hour for tips i'm gonna pay you four
dollars or five dollars an hour
plus your tips this is a minimum it
doesn't preclude someone for doing more
it allows employers to hire good people
and get a and pay them better
uh and i'm all for that that's why i
want to increase i'd increase it to four
dollars for tips and ten dollars
right off the bat because that's what
people are making right now and it takes
away this argument that people aren't
making that
and i don't like the argument um
the phrase that everyone talks about it
was a very poor choice of words
by this the the speaker
what he meant by that is it freezes at
instead of bringing it down to the
federal 219 or whatever it is
that was what i think everyone could
probably agree was meant
it was not meant to say it doesn't
matter if we increase it the feds
increase it or whatever
or if the event decreases let's say to
three dollars let's say this thing gets
passed down in
dc it's ten dollars an hour and maybe
three dollars
they increase the tip wage ours would
have to go back to three no we're
keeping it at 327.
i wish you had said four would have made
it easier
um i would have liked to have seen that
um
why the bill again
this is not a poison pill
but this helps this bill passes it helps
increase the minimum wage
because you no longer have the tipped
wage
lobby coming here and saying we can't
afford it we can't afford it they're
already
making x amount of tips and they're
doing this anyway
um which is surprised by republican
you know it's just like dichotomy you
talked about what you call the venn
diagram
of something earlier um it makes it
easier
uh these folks feel that in the tip
industry that as prices go up
the percentage of the tip goes up so you
pay ten dollars for this and you
20 tip that's two dollars you know you
pay 15 it's
three dollars whatever it goes up uh
that they're getting that anyway with
pure inflation and um and then the
increasing cost
so they're getting a higher tip anyway
this totally removes that argument
for increasing the minimum wage that's
the focus would i like to increase the
minimum wage
say it again get your cameras ready
i'm one of the republicans that wants to
increase the minimum wage number one i
think it's a joke
that we're paying people not eight
not eight fifty not nine
not even ten dollars an hour to do the
most menial tasks
uh imaginable
we're paying more than that and we can't
get employees and they're
hiring people for more and bonuses and
cell phones
amazon mcdonald's when do
what's yours denny's
uh amazon have all decided to increase
to a minimum 10 10 12 an hour they're
all agreeing to this
now not every single job for every
single
employer is going to be that way but a
significant majority and there are jobs
to be had
um so
hey you want to make it harder to
increase the minimum wage don't vote for
this
um but uh this is coming from a i guess
not a conservative enough republican
uh on the issue but anywhere that 45
if i may at this late hour
um i guess i'm
kind of in the same boat with
representation
that is i'm sick of hearing about
minimum wages and stuff i don't know
anybody
who's actually making less than
the minimum wage as it is and
i have if we can use witnesses
i have a grandson who is
working for a pizza outlet
in newport newport so everybody will
understand is in the it's the county
seat
of the second poorest county in the
state
he is making eighteen dollars an hour
sorry
fifteen dollars an hour
tips and
the drivers that are running
service to your home or wherever you
want it
are making similar money plus tips
so i will vote for this
for the reasons that i hope everybody
understands we are
making or people are making far more
than the minimum wage and i would much
rather
let the market dictate
what the wages are thank you
so you know other comments here in the
lob or online the motion on the floor
is
senate bill 137 ought to pass
with amendment number 1596 page vice
representative seaworth mr clerk please
paul
role
see where it votes yes
yes
[Music]
president nunes votes yes
representative votes yes
representative churchill votes yes
representative wow votes yes
avoid vote yes
representative rudy
rudy vote snow
representative cahill
representative especially
representative of the speaker votes no
representative schmidt schmidt votes no
representative toomey
votes no
representative bouchard representative
blueshad
votes no representative
i'd like to have blurbs again today on
both hills
send it to me by email as you always
have
uh stay tuned for the music conference
as we
um get responses from the senate and
i'll see you all
at the house session any further
business in front of this committee
chairman this is christina um as this is
a calendar day i was
hoping we could try to get them in by
three o'clock at the latest
for the blurbs if folks are able to do
that
i recently heard she made me move it
we will do what we can proceed to take
care of that uh
folks try to get those to me by three
o'clock i would appreciate it
and mr chairman if the uh minority
knows what their recommended motion
and who their author are going to be i
can put that in my form
if they're still thinking about it yes
if you could let us know
let you know what i know thank you
representative
all right thank you everyone